M
REAMG AINNDGAIN "I'M
NOSUICIDAL BUTONIG, BK
WITH IS IORTA WNINGROMPRIDENTRUM
JOE DESCONOC POLICSA
ULD NLEA A ECONOMI
WELL HE WARE.OPORTIO."
RECO HIGGA PRIS,EANI
THEIGHE EVE
ANEM GWTH.
HISTOR LEVS OF ILATI, AT
40 YR HIGH.
OCTOBE INFTION WAS 6
EN J BECAME PSIDENT,Y
TH WAY HE IERIT 1%.
ANYW, INOVEMR,T W EVE
HIGHERIN DECBER, EVE HIGHER A 7.
FO THEIR TE I DECES.
IN JUARY A 40EAR HIGH,
7..
ATHOPPG 7%.MBE CAMOUJUST TODAY,E
AND  ACTUALLWOULBE A L
LIKEHE FERALOVERNMENID
WELL,F Y'R CALCULAD UNG
THE D METHOD ITOULD BE OR
INFLIONAS REPORD WL
BERELADIR PUN'SNVASION
UKRNEBE
BRRY 2H.
BUT AORDI TO JOE DEN D
ING THECAN BME O- O
EVERHING, ADIM PUTIN,  IS L
VLIMIRUT'S FAU
TODAS INATIORERT,
TH AMERICA BUDTS A BEIE
STTCHEBY PRI IREES,
FE THEEALMPAC OF PUTIS
ICE HE.
DAY, PSA DOUEDOWN ON
COMPIES. CULIT, GREED O
LET'SLAMEHEM.
KE AOOK.
WEEKHAT UR GAS PRIS HAVE
GO UP.
I WA TO TALTO YOU LTLE
BIT OUTHY.
AND LOT OF I H TO DO WH
ADIM PUT.
♪ ♪BU PAR OF THI IS ON THEIL
RIGH NOW, TRE ARE,000
APPRED USED PERTS THA OIL
AN GASOMPANIESOULDAPNT
NOW T RAM UP PDUION.
E ONLY W T PTECTHE
ITED STAS OV THEONG-RM
ISO BECOMENERNDEPENDE.
ATS W TRESINTAS
BE SO FUSED ON INVTING IN
CLEAENER TECHNOLIES,O
AT WCAN LY ONHATND N
OF GAS.INO SETHE PRI
>> Sn: OBVIOUS, J PSAKI
NOWUDITNI FORAKE WS
CNNR MNC, FIT I PERCTLY,
YOU EDOTOPYING.IKE TT.
IS IA TT PUTIN BECSE
ST YR'OILND GAS SPI IS
AIE.
TH NEETOTOPYING THA
PUN CAUD JOE'S0 YEA HIGH
WE HAD TT 4 YEAR HH BERE
THMOSTECENNUMBS FROM
LA MON, RSIA IADED
ASORMER OBA AISORTEVERANEROINTSR
SMALL RSIA EFFT, FRAYS
RTH.
NER GOG T HAPPEN. COMHEEEDSO O I
HIS OWN PTY'SLIMA ALARMISCU, AST
MOREPENDG, TY WT ZO
MESTIC PDUCTN OF FOSL
ELS.
THEY OWNOE BEN, THEOWN
EMBAASSMENT,ND JY CAMPAN
YOU MIGHT REMBE HE TOLD U
WOU DO ER BIT OF THI>>F WEON'TI
>> WARE L DEAD.
BSIDS FOR FSIL FUE.
NUMBERNE.
NUMB TWO HOLNG TM
CASEWHERE YO UNDSERVED PAICULLYO
IGHBHOS ANOU KNOWHE
AL, OKAANBY T WAY WHE THEY DOT
I WANTOU T JT TAK AOOK,
OKAYYODON' HE TO AGR, B
I GUANTE YOU, IUARAEE
FU, AN I A N GOI TOFSIL
>> WLDHEREE ALACEOR
FRKINGIN AIDENINCO A
>> N W WOUOR IT OUT.
WE WOULD ME SE,LIMITE
ALWA BEEHEIR GOAHISAS
THASHE PROSE.
EI PROSE ISOW BNG
LFILLED.
TH KNOW THE ERGY
STRICTIO ANDAMPA
ENNG O CAUNG GRICES
YEARIGH NFLAONMAKNOWHATHE ARAGE
AMERAN FILYS HTI
BEUSOF TSE PICIE BUT
THEY D'T CE.
THEYARE ME ABOHE RADAL
NOW LIST TO THI CLI FM
DEN' ENERGYECRERY,HE
DE THESEOMMES I NEMBER,
ASASRICE WER ARRING
ARISG THEN.
>>HAT THERAND OLD PN TINEASEILN
AMERIC>> [LAUGHS]
WOULD TT I HAD T MIC WANONHIS.
AS Y KNOW, OOURSIL IA
OBALARKET.ITS COROLLED BAARTE A
RTELS CALLED OPE A
TH MAD T DISION YTERDTH WERNOTOA
BEYO WHA TYERE ALRDY
PLANNI.
Sea THA W INOVBER,
THE TIM GAS PRICES RE
SINGRAMATICAY.
NNIF GRAOL THIS IS
NNY,ID NOTARE, DIDOTHI
TONCREE MEST PDUCTION
CAE TT W AGAST THE
ATED POLY.
COUNY, A VT MAJITY OFI
AMERANS, NEARLY 80%,HEY
WANT TSOUNT TO IREASEOUWNILND EN
ADNISTRATI DOENOT CAR
THEY A FULOF EUSESNDHE ARICAPEL.
PUMPPANG ME T HEA AND
OL YOUROME, PING MORFOR
ERYROCT Y BUY ATVERY
ANDHAT' OKAYITH EM.
THEYAREORE OUT THEINEW
GREEDEAL SOCLISTRIENTHBVIOLY HAR
FLUEE INHE AMERIN
OPLESOET'SACE IT.
THEY A NOT UTO T JOB,
ONOMAL, ANTHISS
RTINOUR NATIAL SURY,ONOP O EVER,
BECAUSNOWHEYREILLI TO
GO,HAT,AG MEDURAN
NEZUA A G TO T IRAAN
LLAH A IMPT OIL FM IRD BPECHATES
REJEING E DEN ERYIME
YOU ASK HO IREASE
PRODUCON?
EVERNE KNO JOE BID IS
AK,E IA COGNITE MES,
MUCHNYTHG THEYANT.JO ISITHE UNWR
UNABLE T TRAL ABROA SO HE
ALWA SENDS KALA RRISN
SHE'BVIOUSLYN WA WAYAY
OVER HER HEAFO EXAMPLE THIEEK, E
TODA SHE DOE NOT RLLYEER
HAVENY GRASPN MH O
ANHING
PRTY HUMILTINGOR T
COTRY.
TA A LOOK.
YOU CIDE>> AM HER STAING HEREN
E NOHERN FLA, OHE
EASTNLANK TALKINGBOUT
EASTERN FNK AND O NAT
I WTOEERY CLEAR.
THE ITEDTATE ANDOLD A
IT IN AT W HAVE DE ANAR PPARE TP
UKRAIN ANDHE PEOPLOF
RAINFU SP.
THE TELEVION CERAG JUST
STERY.
AT'S ON P OFVERYTHIN ELSTH W KN,
ABLE TO SEEND BECSE WE HASE ITRT
SN'T HAPNED.
BUJUST LIT IOHAT W
HAVE SN.
>> Sn: FLONG TSE
REMARKRUMP'S AING DNI
RIGRELL,WEET "OH, DR
GOD,HISS A TOTISASR.
SHES NREPARED.
SHISN'GRASPINGSSUE A
NEVE ACCATEL VETTINGER.
LIEVIT OR NO ACTLLYOT
RSE.
E VICE ESIDT, THAT ANSVI PREDEND
REFUES WH O OHER RLD
FAMO LGHIN FITS.THAT RHT, THEICT
GGNG BOREHE WLD WHE
ASKE ABO WT D WEO WIT
WAREFUGEES.
TCH URSE.
>> IS TH UNID STATES WILNG
FOR RAINN REFEES?ON
D FO PREDENT DUD I WTED
TO KW IYOUHINK A IF UASD TH UNIO
REFUGEES.YCCEPT MO
OKA
AUGHTER]
FRND IEEDS A FRIE
INDE.
[LGHTER]>>KAY,O-
>> Sn: THEAR IUKRAE,
T'S SEEHEY AOMNG
WE HE MSRAVE WIT 70ORE
PEOP INT, THE HUMITARIAN
CRIS INASTE EOPE ERYSERIS.
AT AE GNGO DOITHHE
FUGEES?
THETAKECOUL'TE HIGHER,
D ROPES O T EDG OF A
TEIAL RLD R TT'S GOT
TO BVOID, AND KALA DUING P, LGHA
SIC QSTIOSHNEVE GAVE AONESNSWE